right there you go so what's happening
is they America doesn't understand and I
guess women don't understand that what
they're doing is that they're pushing
their men away so they're pushing their
men away to these other countries and
then cursing them out for going to these
other countries while pushing them away
so it's it's a it's a whole vicious
cycle of what's gone in America I
actually think like you said America's
birthday is going to get like Japan's
and what's going to happen what is going
to happen is that Americans are going to
have be having babies with other women
from other countries and America's gonna
I think we're seeing the fall of America
that's just think we're seeing it in
real time it's abused so what do you say
if I don't want you no one else can have
you and you see these women it's like oh
they're broken Dusty they can't get
women they can't get up over women like
me but that's why they have to go there
but they reject these men treat these
men like crap and then when they go and
these men and first of all this is pride
I think you're better than a woman in
another country just because she's in
another country you're so much better
than her that just shows like you're are
all for women and you want women to win
but yet these women from these other
countries they're poor they'll just get
with a man for a sandwich I mean I've
just seen the most deranged things learn
from them it's abusive why don't we
learn it's like absolutely if someone's
if someone's getting an a in a class you
don't get mad at them you take notes
we're actually winning facts it's Pride
we feel like we own our men in our
culture and and it's like if I reject
you and a lot of times women are not
wanting to compete if I use the word
compete with women they're just like I
don't think you should like me for me
they want they don't want you having
more options outside of what they're
giving you so like they want you to
accept their lower standards I think
that's why women shame men for having
standards is because then they don't
have to compete for a man absolutely if
we can convince him that we're the best
and we're have slept around we're
overweight we're like anything that a
guy when we're older then we don't have
to compete we don't have to bring
anything else to the table modern women
today will shame insults and modern
women today will shame and so and guilt
you out of your standards
they will shame and soul guilt you out
of your requirements and how can we
improve if we don't even admit there's a
problem if you're overweight the first
thing you have to do is weigh yourself
but as women we can't even weigh
ourselves without pointing at the men no
I really do believe like on a deeper
note I believe we're watching the fall
of a Nation right in front of our eyes I
actually believe that we're watching The
Fall of the western General right in
front of our eyes and I and I said the
women the way and I say that because the
women are degenerating in my personal
opinion the women are degenerating the
whole the whole society goes to pot
um the men are now saying that they can
be women now what you know what I'm
saying so I'm saying the whole society
is going to pop so we can sit here and
because for me I think it's not just
relationships that need saving
whole society
do you think looking at women you can
tell what a society looks like if you
want to see what a society looks like
you look like 100
you can look at society and and that is
why men are flying over from the West to
another country and get in play the
women from this country from the West
they can't fly over summer us to go
again man no no absolutely
there's no way I'm dealing with that
if women cannot go we don't have the
same if if Western men can are not
wanting us and and can't deal with us we
can't get a man here men from more
traditional countries which the vast
majority of the other countries in the
world are way more traditional than the
West especially the U.S I don't know
about the UK but the the us if the men
there say that you're a hot mess and
they're not wiping you up you're not
gonna go to Italy uh you know Portugal
or or Brazil and and get a man unless
he's trying to get a Visa I gotta I
gotta contradict that because I'm the
digital Nomad right I'm the person who's
traveling and going to these places
however I will say that I have an open
mindset that I'm going in culturally
into you guys this point I want to study
from the from the a student right I want
to understand their culture more what do
you disagree with I'm just I'm not
disagreeing I'm just providing a
different perspective of a woman you
said you disagree with that so I was
just wondering disagree with what what
part of what he said oh no no no I'm I'm
following behind um Melanie here or I'm
sorry yeah with the fact of women not
being able to do that and so I'm saying
as a digital Nomad who is doing doing
that who has been knowing that since the
pandemic my experience has been
different but it's because I'm coming
into these cultures and I'm
understanding to your point I'm studying
the a student you're submissive nature
your culture right what are we not doing
in America that we should be doing
better right because we aren't getting
it over there so that's been my mindset
so I've literally been in Portugal I'm
literally in London and I've getting hit
on from guys all the time who are
seriously wanting relationships they're
wanting marriage and it's because I'm
making friends in these different
cultures and they're teaching me be
submissive you know learn a little bit
and this is how we serve our men this is
how we cater to them this is how we are
um you know providing that and I'm
honestly American women should be doing
it more it's life-changing it is sorry
let me let me come on real quick Sarah
said something that was incredibly
important and I just don't want to skip
through it because it was so important
you said that the direction and the way
that we are moving right now is leading
to the fall of our society that's
correct and if you think about what has
been the Cornerstone to build the west
and the Cornerstone has been hard
working men
hard working men but the hard-working
man today gets no respect that's right
the sanitation worker the construction
worker
the plumber
they get no respect today and it's just
that's why on my channel I ensure that
these men get air time frequently the
oil rig workers oh if you just
strip them off today our world would be
in Calamity even today
and these same exact men don't get
respect yep and the thing is I think to
myself like what why is that
the Modern Woman today has been tricked
that her education is correlated to her
intelligence or it's correlated to the
type of man that she is owed
her worth is equivalent to that yeah and
it's so here here's the thing
digital nomad
would you date a blue-collar man a
hard-working man absolutely I'm dating
right now I just I mentioned that that's
my status in dating and what's he doing
he drives he's a driver he's a trucker
shout out to the truckers driver yep so
I I absolutely and not to mention just a
digital Nomad I'm a business attorney
right I went to college at 16. I
definitely have accolades but I'm not
leading that as my Forefront I didn't
come from I'm trying to be that's not
that's not what I lead with right I very
rarely even it's not that I'm hiding it
but I don't want to talk about that I
want to get to know you for you what is
your character like what are you that's
what I want to marry that's what I'm
interested in so I don't really care
what you do honestly because I my
mindset is as a woman as a wife what a
wife brings to the table honey is I'm
going to equip it and value us if you
got a dream and a mission baby I'm gonna
take that and I'm gonna flourish it I'ma
cultivate it because that's what I
believe women are purpose to do right
but do you believe that men from other
countries are looking at women in
America specifically thinking I want
that American woman absolutely not right
absolutely but I approach currently
right I'm not coming over there's the
American girl I'm coming over I have
friends in the culture I'm I'm in their
culture I'm immersed and now they're
they're in they're interested in me
right they're like what's different
about you right you're not the American
girl you're not who we see on TV you're
not the culture and it Sparks
conversation and then they get to see me
and they're talking to me and they're
like it's something different about her
just like Camille you can notice a
unicorn in the room by how she speaks
how she talks that's how you know a wife
is how she talks I think the downfall of
America specifically as a Brit as one of
the only Brits on this run away I think
one of the downfall of them of Americans
has been the ego and Americans for very
long have thought that America is the
world right and so the world kind of
revolves around American it's the
greatest nation not realizing that all
of this other time the rest of the world
has always existed the the Saudi arabias
I don't know the the thailands the
Philippines the the African nations and
then what's happened is the ego has
grown so big that it started to kind of
implode on itself when it comes to
America and everyone's like
we we were trying to tell you we were
trying to tell you you need to be a
little bit more humble so it's happening
with the women specifically in America
and I love American women like I really
do I think American women are great I'm
telling but I'm saying the ego that has
been allowed to inflate itself and then
what is going to happen is the rest of
the world are actually watching and
laughing correct at the women in America
that oh my God look at these women they
they literally I've seen women in
America literally have a vibratory
device and make it and make a video
about how good it is and how much better
of a man it is than a man no shame no
the average modern woman podcast they
all are sponsored by Men by women's
devices I'm just like what no other
woman outside the America would do that
can I be honest as an American woman I
thought like that and I would I will own
it and it wasn't for me and this is what
I think is happening in American culture
is that we are under this disillusion
and we have this ego and we thinking
that we're better and we're not going to
push our men away and oh I deserve to be
married and from me I personally had to
have this life Awakening and it happened
to me around 28 29 and I literally had
to stop dating for a while a season I
went to therapy I went to counseling and
I had to change how I thought and I
viewed things and what my positioning
was and what I needed to do differently
so Lauren wouldn't look at herself at 60
and go there you go oh I didn't take
accountability right back to our word
for the evening I didn't take
accountability and that's why I'm single
right so I had to do that and I'm now
yielding the results of that it took
some time as the garden I had to
cultivate it had to get some ground in
there and now we're seven years in and
I'm seeing the Harvest of that I'm the
men that I attract quality even though
they might not be oh top tier jobs and
things like that but their characters
sets them apart and that's what I want
is your character not necessarily your
job amen so I'm it's you did you hear
what she said she said she said take
accountability she she owned up to that
the way you just spoke and talked about
how you had to own your stuff you rarely
hear that about from women and
especially in the U.S and I think the
reason why the U.S we have such a big
head is because we own we own
entertainment and entertainment owns
culture so Hollywood music all of that
we've we've spread to the world through
that our tendrils have reached culture
we're not talking about you know
military and all that but if we want to
talk about that we own movies television
and music it's period And So It has gone
out like I remember I would go to
another country and our movies will be
on with subtitles and I'm like or I
would meet people from other countries
like oh yeah I know Fresh Prince of
Bel-Air and I'm like like you grew up
with it and they're just like yeah but
they would grow with the subtitles and I
we I used to be as American I'm just
like like what like this weird to me
like why don't you have your own but I
think it's because about in the U.S it's
all about consumption it's all about
being entertained everything is like you
know even social media we started all of
that dating apps we started all of that
because it's just our culture is this
very back course and then we wonder why
what's wrong I mean and but it gives us
a false sense of Pride because we think
oh we're everybody wants to be like
everybody wants to be like us but we
don't realize half the stuff like people
are looking around laughing at us right
right except for China they steal
everything yeah but they still like
culturally it's like we have this Pride
which I think you should have pride in
where you're from but it's a false
bravado that's actually destructive and
it's blind Pride as well it's
destruction who do you think's more
afraid of commitment men or women oh um
I think for marriage I think men men
yeah what do you think men or women I
think it's equal but women are afraid of
commitment because they feel like
they're going to lose their life which
is a false fear men are afraid of
commitment because they fear they're
going to lose their livelihood which is
a real fear
um
I think is 50 50 as well
um I agree with you
um that woman they want they don't want
to feel like they're missing out and
you know they don't want to feel it
depends on the culture because I was
speaking to a woman from Nigeria and she
was saying about how
her and her ex-husband before they could
get that divorce it would be loads of
family meetings and now she worries for
her children because well not
necessarily because
um you know she's the head of the family
but
if it was to be that they wanted to go
into marriage everyone would kind of be
involved like especially on the woman's
side so I think it depends on the
culture
um could you guys pick one if you have
to pack men or women
so the question was who is afraid more
of commitment
women
men men I was I had a hypothesis when I
started this that the older people in
the room would say men and the younger
people would say women because the
younger men don't know
but it didn't really go out like that
um okay I'm gonna Read Super chats
really quick and then I think we're
gonna close out the show um this was
a lot of fun guys thank you all for
coming tonight
okay
um
okay Brighton um truth is truth is lies
and lies is truth um Tomo J Alpha widows
to their toys a wine cat food and
vibrators invest away boys
um sentience 100 super essential
[Applause]
hello sentence we missed you we missed
you come back
um the only commitment phobe is the
salty gamer who is scared to be
ridiculed by the chat as we drink those
delicious tears Melanie kudos to you for
talking about me regaining your purpose
and retaining from your Hiatus a purpose
is a Daily Commitment to yourself cheers
mate PJ I'm the high paid blue-collar
man I'm one get a lot of respect just
not from Western women so there is an
incentive to be blue collar and import
lazy Prodigy um shout out to the real
MTR and Melanie King I'm Jacob Joseph
watch birth Gap by Stephen J Shaw to see
how low birth weight rates will bring
down the western civilization and how
childlessness hurts everyone but
especially women
Tomo J how can a man commit when only 10
percent of men play distinguish Chad and
Chad lights from 85 percent of average
sub Five Guys stop the cope if women
locked them up the rotation would not be
so effing broken um Dumbledore as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible